beginning of Gaming starter rolls when
you first start learning to do Aikido
Kimmy can be a big challenge starter
rolls are a nice way to ease yourself
into the rolling practice forwards
usually particularly difficult one of
the great starter roles I like to use is
a kneeling roll
the knee light rule starts from this
position with one leg up and one leg
down once I'm in this position I'm going
to take one arm and reach through my
legs
this will allow me to get my shoulder
really close to the ground
and then kick my legs over so what's
nice about this is it keeps the angle
pretty true to a regular roll you also
kind of get the feeling of going forward
which is an essential part of rolling
but it's still not dramatic there's not
a big range to fall from and you can
take the time to set yourself up
perfectly so again I'm going to take
this arm the same arm as the knee that's
down so if my right knee is down I'm
going to use my right arm I'm going to
reach my right arm through my legs going
right through my legs I'm going to place
my shoulder on the mat and let myself
over
kneeling Rolla is a pretty easy starter
role the only difference is there's some
there's a moment where I'm not going to
have a lot of control so it might be a
little frightening for some people but
it's nice you don't have to have a lot
of core strength and there's not a lot
of momentum required give it a try and
see how it works for you kneeling roll
I'm Christopher Hyman thanks for
watching